christophe maé est l'invité de là où ça
bouge ce soir il est en concert ici au
normandie on va essayer de retrouver
dans la salle avel ar excusez moi mais
c'est beaucoup
un mini colloque faut qu'on le voit là
c'est en quelques minutes c'est pas
grave on va pas se fâcher on va
retrouver tout de suite sabine daniel
qui est en compagnie d'un jeune homme
c'est pour parler de marionnettes au
théâtre des cordes et c'est à caen voile
et ensuite on rendra dans la salle post
chum banon poursuit des bisous
je suis avec louison leduff mon
stagiaire pour vous présenter ce
spectacle de marionnettes qui s'intitule
cendres et qui se joue au théâtre des
cordes ici à caen et c'est bien sûr dans
les cadres des boréales
c'est du coup inspiré de ce roman de
l'auteur norvégien galles tae bo avance
avant que je me consume ça s'appelle le
livre et ça parle du coup de feu se fait
et réelle de un pyromane qui en 1978 à
brûler tout un village dans le sud de la
norvège et en mettant son sein en
parallèle sa propre vie l'auteur y ouvre
à la folie à l'intérieur de chaque
humain la littérature au le l'oeuvre
littéraire est très important pour moi
dans la création de spectacles mais je
travaille surtout sur comment traduire
la matière même de l'écriture aux images
a situation en mouvement sont pour que
pour créer des morceaux qui mis ensemble
nous raconte une histoire posés choisi
de ne pas mettre de dialoguer parce que
pour moi c'était plus fort de raconter
cette histoire par les images ou par les
situations cendres de la compagnie
plexus solaire c'est ce soir ou demain à
20 heures au théâtre des cordes à caen
et voilà la trappe rêve nous sommes sur
la scène donc du normandy à saint lô
avec christophe maé merci beaucoup de
nous accueillir sur votre scène vous
allez faire trois dates très importante
chez nous en normandie en 2017 ou ans
quand le havre à tous vous écrire en bas
de l'écran
ce soir est ce qu'on peut dire ce
concert ici à saint lô c'est une pré
tournée vous êtes déjà à fond parce que
ça fait huit dates
c'est le début de la tournée on prend la
température nous est née acker en tous
les cas de démarrer on appelait ça le
pré tour parce que en fait c'est une
petite formation et c'est vrai que ça
depuis une dizaine d'années j'ai la
chance de faire des grandes salles des
zéniths et là ça me tenait à coeur de
retourner dans des salles intermédiaire
pour retrouver une proximité et une
interaction qu'on n'a pas dans les
grandes salles
phrase et je suis entouré de mes
musiciens c'est la rythmique on est on
se retrouve cinq sur scène et c'est vrai
que dans les zéniths
on va avoir une des cours
supplémentaires avec un écran géant des
images tournées en amont c'est plus les
mêmes musiques les mêmes tunique famille
ses portes et ses veaux catholique je la
vois mains souvent parce que madame
r j'ai démarré cet album en écrivant les
textes les albums précédents je faisais
la musique et après je mettais des mots
sur la musique est là c'est vrai que
j'ai d'abord écrit tous mes textes puis
après je les ai prises je les ai mis en
musique et j'avais vraiment envie de
faire de prendre ce virage de faire un
bilan sur sur la quarantaine quoi me
raconter être plus en dans
l'introspection et raconter qui je suis
vraiment quoi
j'ai fait des folies j'ai pris des fous
rires je croyais être heureux quel
chemin depuis le roi soleil
je mets ma magnifique s'est passé s'est
passé à une vitesse une allure voilà
c'est assez incroyable ça fait déjà 10
ans c'est la cerise sur le gâteau d'être
sur la sur la route de rencontrer les
gens allez les voir avant de monter sur
scène de papoter un peu avec eux voilà
c'est si je fais ce métier vraiment
cessé pour ça pour échanger avec les
gens et ils vous le rendent très bien
d'ailleurs il me le rend très bien parce
que d'ailleurs je vais en profiter pour
leur dire merci merci d'être là au
rendez vous parce que là on part c'est
le début de la tournée et les salles se
remplissent franchement bien et donc
comme ça va nous permettre de voir
d'aller faire la fête avec avec tous ces
gens là quoi merci beaucoup plus top
merci à vous
hélas